hi everyone in this video i'm going to
give you my 20 best gift ideas for men
and it doesn't matter if it's for your
son
for your husband your boyfriend
your father your grandfather there's
going to be a gift in here for them now
let's not waste any more time let's get
to it
[Music]
all right now the best gift that you can
give any man is your time because that's
more precious than any material thing
but let's take a look at the list of
gifts that you can add to your time
good skincare products when it comes to
skin care it's always better to get
something that actually works that makes
a man feel like a gentleman
so try to move away from these cheap
drugstore products that usually don't
work and get a good skincare routine
like geology geology is a personalized
skincare brand you just basically go to
their website and select all the
skincare problems he might have and they
deliver it to you now of course this is
my personal choice because i use it
myself but there are also other good
options like pc for men
tj hanley
and even clinique
now i'll add all the links and the
discount codes especially from my
viewers in the video description down
below if you want to check it out
cologne
you can never go wrong with good cologne
well
that is unless you don't know a lot
about cologne and you get something that
doesn't really smell good my favorite
three are vince camuto terra versace
eros and dulcinea cabana the one for men
and again i'll add a few extra options
in the video description down below and
i'm gonna do that with all the tips in
this video now let's move on
fun toys look
boys are gonna be boys even when they
get 80 years old so get them something
fun like a dji drone
or if you're on a low budget a fidget
cube if he likes fidgeting or the cool
retro handheld gaming console
or if he's young you can get him a
second gen boosted board
if he likes board games getting risk or
another cool game
oh yeah
and every man would probably like a
small putting green
i hope my wife is watching this video
[Music]
a pocket knife every guy needs a good
looking manly pocket knife
it always comes in handy especially if
you go outdoors and you can put your
personal touch on it by getting him an
engraved pocket knife
a wallet a lot of guys
they use the same wallet for years past
their lifetime and then it it looks bad
it looks unprofessional so get him a
nice wallet preferably a slim rfid
wallet like this one in a day that we
live in you need this technology rfid
will protect him his data from any
themes
ear products there's a lot of guys out
there with beards but some of them they
don't know how to take care of their
beards the products to use to groom
their beards to look
classy
you'll need a basics like a beard comb
oil
and wax i prefer honest amish but of
course i'll add a few good options for
you down below
leather jacket there's just something
special about a leather jacket for a guy
i mean when you put it on it just it
just feels rugged manly and you will
never go out of style this is super
important this is a special gift maybe
when it turns 20
or even 50 it also looks good on older
guys
i recommend angel jackets because they
have real leather jackets for under two
hundred dollars that look amazing
a beard shaver or trimmer if you like
trimming his beard i mean
this is a no-brainer because he's gonna
use it almost every day of his life and
if you get him one he's gonna think of
you every time he's gonna use it
good quality headphones or earphones
that blocks out all the noise you know
especially if he travels a lot i used to
travel a lot public transport
airports always just
noise noise noise noise and you get
really tired of it but then you put on
those headphones that cancels all the
noise you're at peace
[Music]
coffee a lot of guys love coffee i love
coffee a lot so get him good quality
coffee or
if he already has a lot of good quality
coffee then get him good coffee
equipment or a coffee maker here are
some good options a nice french press
plunger a coffee grinder
a siphon
an aeropress
a portable mini presser
a mocha pot
or an espresso coffee maker
there's a lot of options something tells
you i love coffee right
[Music]
a ticket to his favorite game if you
love sport baseball football rugby or
tennis well it doesn't actually matter
what sport he likes just get him a
ticket to his favorite game to the team
that he supports
and he will love
botox or shall i say beef jerky but you
can't really say that because bolton is
just so much better
than beef jerky bolton is a south
african thing and if he loves meat he's
gonna love bolton or if you don't live
in south africa just getting beef jerky
south african men man we love
bolton or if he doesn't really like meat
just get him a gift basket with a mix of
his favorite treats
and he will like it we have a saying in
afrikaans ipad from
it basically just means
the way to a man's heart goes through
his stomach
get him something for his hobby if he
loves fishing it's easy get him a new
fishing rod a tackle box or a nice
fishing shirt cap or even gloves he'll
love him or if he has another hobby get
him something that he can use
guys
don't usually like things that they
cannot use
like ornaments you know a white elephant
thing
a book
if he loves reading why not get him a
book something that fits in with his
character what he likes what he would
prefer
action adventure detective or mystery or
it could even be a book about his hobby
i hope my wife is listening but i mean i
would love a book about fishing
a weekend away now this is for the wives
out there why not book
a getaway weekend for you and a man that
you love
and then
it's his birthday but you get to go with
him and enjoy it as well
a cool gadget a lot of guys are into
gadgets things that they can use so get
him something like a tesla coil lighter
that's windproof and rechargeable or a
bathroom motion sensor led light oh and
a cool thing most guys don't even think
of is a cool docking station for their
accessories like this wood docking
station from tesler you might also like
a portable solar power back another cool
thing to get if you love scamping is a
multi-tool camping gadget
or even better an emergency survival
gear kit from alex
a smart coffee mug warmer yeah i'm back
with the coffee but you can also use
this with any other warm drink or you
can even get a temperature control smart
mug as well
[Music]
a watch
this is the perfect gift for your son if
he turns 18 a good quality watch or for
your husband
if he's kind of old and doesn't look
that good anymore every man needs a good
quality watch and you don't need to
break the bank to get him a nice watch
for example check out these nice watches
from vincero
[Music]
a small concrete fireplace i mean this
is just so cool to have you know put it
in his man cave you know when you have a
few friends over and you just put that
thing in the middle and you just have
conversations around it you share
stories it's cool you can get this from
flickr
you can also get a portable campfire on
amazon
a nice bag now of course this depends on
what he needs so
just
keep your eyes out next time he goes to
the gym or he goes to work or he goes
just to go camping then all you do is
just replace the bag that's in the worst
condition
now the bonus step well for a surprise
here's actually a few more tips a gift
box with different spices
a foosball cooler a cool bicycle a
charging stand new shoes
a mini outdoor pizza oven portable
bluetooth speakers a breakfast omelette
or sandwich maker cufflinks
and lastly a new toolbox and you
expected just one bonus tip
now if you still don't know what to get
him
just listen to him i mean every guy out
there is unique
so with all those conversations that you
have with him just listen because he
might slip something and then you'll
know exactly what to get now let me know
if you have any other good gift ideas so
we can all check it in the comment
section down below and remember this
guys very important
life is short
so don't waste yours cheers guys